You're looking at the jQuery library.
This is the entire library.
Notice that it's actually just JavaScript.
Let me repeat that.
jQuery is just a JavaScript library.
It's not a language on its own nor is it fundamentally different
than the thousands of other JavaScript libraries available.
There's no magic in here that you couldn't devise yourself.
If we had a week or so,
I'd be willing to bet that you could recreate a lot of jQuery's functionality.
Look at this method, isFunction.
Do you see that?
Look, it's just returning true if the object passed into it
has a type of function.
If you recreated jQuery,
your library probably wouldn't be as performant as jQuery.
But you could pretty easily recreate a lot of the same methods and
functionality that jQuery offers.
jQuery exists largely because manipulating the DOM with
vanilla JavaScript isn't always easy.
For instance, inserting a new DOM node with JavaScript means
creating an element, setting attributes and
content of the new node, selecting the soon-to-be parent of the new node, and
then finally inserting the new node as a child of the parent node.
But with jQuery, all of that is simplified to one simple function.
And no one wants to worry about developing Web sites for
different browsers when all you want to do is concentrate on
creating a Web site with a fantastic user experience.
jQuery exists so that you can focus on UX, not browser quirks.
But before you start writing jQuery functions,
I want you to take a look under jQuery's hood.